LAURA LING: Tens of
millions of young Americans
are drowning in
student loan debt.
But one person is
trying to reinvent
higher ed and the
outrageous cost associated
with getting a degree.
And he's an MIT dropout.
JEREMY ROSSMANN: Our
mission is to provide
the most accessible
highest quality [? CS ?]
education that is really
out there in higher ed.
And a big part of that
is not taking tuition
from students up front,
and instead, taking
a percentage of their salaries.
Because there should not
be a way for a school
to succeed other than
producing successful students.
LAURA LING: Frustrated as
a math and computer science
student at MIT, Jeremy
Rossmann decided
to leave traditional
university life.
By 23, he co-founded
the Make School
in San Francisco, California.
The school's
website describes it
as a college replacement
for founders and developers.
What you're saying is you
guys don't charge any tuition
up front?
JEREMY ROSSMANN: Correct.
There's no gotchas.
There's no tricks.
You're never paying a
dollar you don't have.
It changes a lot.
It means that we
can only stay alive
if our students get
the best education
and get great employment.
LAURA LING: Many of the
Make School students
are college dropouts
like Rossmann
and have left top universities
including Carnegie
Mellon, UCLA, and Columbia.
19-year-old, Jimmy Yue,
decided to leave UC Irvine
and attend the Make
School instead.
He showed me the app
that he just created.
JIMMY YUE: So the
Music Virtualizer, wow.
It's so cool.
All right.
We can point it
at the cameraman.
LAURA LING: OK.
Hi, Alex.
Ah.
Cool, cool.
So when you play
different music--
JIMMY YUE: Right.
LAURA LING: Like, if
you played hip hop,
then Alex would be
doing something else.
JIMMY YUE: It reacts differently
to pretty much everything.
So musical reality.
LAURA LING: What do you feel
you're getting out of the Make
School that you weren't getting
out of a traditional college?
JIMMY YUE: It's definitely
the environment,
how people keep
trying to make things
rather than being
a college where
everyone's like, yeah, we need
to get an A on this next exam.
LAURA LING: The Make School
says they have a 10% acceptance
rate, making it more competitive
than Duke or Dartmouth.
What really
differentiates Make School
from the traditional college?
JIMMY YUE: Several factors.
There's no grades.
There's no tests.
There's no traditional
problem-based homework.
It's all about building things
as you would in the real world.
LAURA LING: Do you
think that students
are taking too big of a risk
to give up formal education?
JIMMY YUE: I think
culturally we've mixed up
the cause and effect
between getting your degree
and having a good
life afterwards.
It's not the degree
that got it for you.
It's what you
learned in the name
of the school and the
connections it brought you.
There's such a big difference
between leaving school
to attend a full-time program
like Make School versus leaving
school to backpack across the
country and find yourself.
LAURA LING: How did your
parents react when you told them
that you were dropping out
of the University of Irvine?
JIMMY YUE: Oh, they were
horrified because they're
very traditional.
They went to university
on their own.
And they got master's.
And they think that
in this age, it's
still you have to go to a good
university just to get a job
and just to work.
[MUSIC PLAYING ]
LAURA LING: Do you
have any regrets
about dropping out of MIT?
JEREMY ROSSMANN:
No strong regrets.
I know that many of my students
will go on to become much more
successful than I will be.
And that when I'm looking
for a job, they will be open
minded enough to look past my
lack of traditional credential
and perhaps offer me one.
LAURA LING: So do
you think one day
you'll be knocking on the
door of one of your students?
JEREMY ROSSMANN:
I'm almost certain.
Yeah.
LAURA LING: Is the cost
of college impacting you?
Tell us how in the
comments below.
And check out this
next episode to meet
artist Jay Nelson, who turns
trash into amazing treehouses.
JAY NELSON: My friends and
I, all through high school,
we just built forts.
We weren't really interested
in girls or-- we just weren't.
We were, like, we were
interested in building
forts and surfing.
We never really grew out of it.
LAURA LING: Thanks for watching.
And be sure to subscribe
to Seeker Stories.
[MUSIC PLAYING]